il ya beaucoup de gens qui vous pose la
question est ce que les commentaires
antisémites compte april benayoun ont
gâché votre victoire
ça n'a pas gâché ma victoire mais je
trouve ça honteux je trouve ça
scandaleux de parler de scandale par dix
bien sûr je les ai eus au téléphone dès
le lendemain puisque moi j'avais perdu
mon téléphone le soir de l'élection je
les retrouver le lendemain soir et la
première chose que j'ai fait d'ailleurs
celui-ci le rescapé d'accord en valois
la viola nos labos alaba destitué et
donc oui et donc mais je les ai eus au
téléphone pour lui demander a commencé à
aller et comment elle réagit c'est
incroyable qu'on puisse voir ça en 2021
ça vous a gâché vous savez le sexy vie
est extrêmement touché par ce qui s'est
passé soit là parce qu'en fait le fier
nous on ne l'a pas vécue l'intérieur
pendant les trois semaines de
préparation à aucun moment donné je
pense à prix n'a été touché et n'a pu
entendre ce genre de commentaire moi je
suis rien été mais vous êtes dans un
coco au fait vous attends moi ça m'a ça
m'a rendu malade en fait qu'en 2021 dans
lequel on est nombreux à croire que l'on
se permette sur une émission une
émission de télé enfin d'ailleurs ça n'a
lieu d'être nulle part mais je comprends
pas qu'aujourd'hui on a encore des gens
qui puissent se cacher derrière les
réseaux sociaux parce que celle de
colonna on en a celui qui avait fait le
truc le plus horrible
voilà je vais pas citer parce que voilà
et apparemment il a été là on l'a
retrouvé un milliard c'est qu'un oui je
sais mais voilà nommé pour vous dire
c'est inadmissible ça a gâché sa gâcher
la fête de tout le monde j'ai trouvé et
je le dis je trouve que c'était une des
plus belles élection de miss france
qu'on ait vu très très longtemps
d'ailleurs on s'est pas trompé en
audience a été un des plus gros cartons
d'audience depuis le réseau d'eau la
soirée était magnifique
les portraits je trouvais que c'était
vraiment une très moderne c'était
beaucoup mieux les les tableaux étaient
magnifiques vraiment joué on s'est
régalé même si c'est vrai ça fait
plaisir d'entendre ce qu'ils sont
vraiment être bien vous savez